in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio now is professor about time vida
man from villains Charity Hospital hello
hello hello welcome I'm a GP myself and
in my office a lot of patients come in
and present themselves with tummy aches
and bloating and so on so how do I know
it's a GP that this is a histamine
intolerance I think we both know that
the diagnosis of a histamine intolerance
is a very difficult one we in contrast
to for instance patient with lactose or
fructose intolerance there we can make
the diagnosis rather easily but in the
case of histamine intolerance there's no
proper diagnosis with a blood test or
also with regards to a tissue a
diagnosis in an endoscopy example so
there we can only do it by an
elimination diet that is we expose the
patient to a histamine and see it as
done in the patient here where we see if
the patient then reacts in a way that
causes the symptoms the patient was
reporting so so we just leave tomatoes
out of the diet and see if it helps that
is what we have recommend the patient
the moment they complain about symptoms
that we cannot really diagnose by
standard procedures and is this is your
periodic approach as well just leaving
away all the stuff which you could cause
the intolerance that's mainly the case
in the field of food intolerance but of
course we have other tests we can talk
about later and in most patients are not
born with histamine intolerance
sometimes in life just appears what
triggers the onset I think individually
we have a different train system to deal
with substances especially in the
Western world we can digest or not and
they of course some heritage inherited
diseases or intolerance is where we just
do not have the enzymes that break down
lactose or fructose
and that uncut in turn leads then to the
symptoms which had been also here
reported in the patient and if my
patients say they don't want to leave
tomatoes out of their dinner plan and is
it okay just to try it with supplements
vitamins we got a viewer question Nina
however from Canada once know this are
supplements enough to treat histamine
intolerance I think this remains a wish
fact is that all the supplements do not
work okay and you said it already there
are different kinds of intolerance s not
just histamine there's lactose and
fructose and dimples I think what the
main three causes we can diagnose of
intolerance are lactose fructose and
also gluten okay these are substances
where we can make a proper diagnosis
both by a tissue as well as in the blood
and also some tests like in breast tests
and there we can tell the patient's for
sure if he has this kind of intolerance
or not and in what's going wrong inside
the bodies is take for instance lactose
intolerance the problem is that since
the substance the patient ingests cannot
be broken down the substance moves
further down in the abdomen attract and
GI tract and there it causes bloating
and causes also a change in the
microbiome in the bacterial flora and
that imgur in turn leads to the symptoms
like cramps diarrhea etc and if you look
around the world lactose intolerance
affects people in different parts of the
world and a different amount take in
Asia for instance a lot of people have
lactose intolerance is this true for
other types of food intolerances as well
I think what we learned over the years
is that of course the food habits
changed especially in the Western world
and therefore of course we have a train
system over there thousands of years in
humans that are only ready to break down
certain substances but if we look for
instance the Western world we have a lot
of preservatives now in the food we have
also changed our diets with regard to
tremendous quantities of fructose like
for instance in Coke and that of course
leads also too impatient that usually
not exposed or used to that to the given
symptoms so and if you suggest that
there's some food intolerance in a
patient of yours
what do you do what kind of procedures
do you to it you do to test it I think
what we have to do is the first place to
a breath test with regards to glucose
and also fructose tolerance and once we
have both tests wrong that is
pathological then we have to look for a
bacterial overgrowth which is quite
common and once we have that then we
have to go into more detail asking is
there celiac disease present or is there
some other cause especially once the
patients come from the tropical areas
and you have to distinguish em food
intolerance with food allergy absolutely
yeah we got a view am sunil kumar from
India and he wants to know what's the
difference between boses well there's a
big difference in the one case you just
have some abdominal cramps and diarrhea
and some discomfort it's the that's
intolerance and in the other case you
really deal with vitally in a dangerous
situation where patient develops aside
from a swelling of the face also
breathing problems and the patient in
the extreme has to be intubated in order
to secure his life so there's a complete
difference with the patient's symptoms
and also patient life expectancy and in
the case of allergies you don't even
need a large amount of the allergic
substance like an take nuts for instance
absolutely in the case of allergy a
small amount already suffices to cause
they're given symptoms within
intolerance you have a quantity
dependent effect and avoiding the food
you are allergic to is one solution of
course but are there any other things
like medication or drugs you can take
well I think what you need is an
emergency kit in kink in the case you
exposed to some of the elegance and
there you clearly have to reuse this
kind of emergency pack with you all the
time in order to be not in a situation
where you exposed to the very dangerous
irritant so it might be dangerous not to
have an emergency pack there but in food
intolerance this is it dangerous not to
treat them or can you just leave it if
it don't bother you sir I think you can
leave it it doesn't affect your life
expectancy of however I think your
quality of life is clearly impaired and
there you have to adjust
according to what you can eat and what
you cannot it via email thanks so much
for being with us in the studio today
thank you welcome
you